[Music]
hello hello and welcome to lesson four
on prototyping and saving plots in the
previous lesson we went over the basics
of creating and customizing scatter
plots and box plots in r
these are the two most common types of
plots for ecologists
but that won't really help you much if
you don't know how to export these plots
from
r so that you can use them in your
publications and presentations
so in this lesson i'm going to go over a
simple but very effective method for
prototyping your plots until they look
just right and then exporting them
first let's upload the data and plot
that we made in the previous lesson
so let's let's load the data of course
first and then if we run the levels
function on
plant growth group we can see that those
levels are
labeled ctrl trt1 and tr22 let's give
them something more meaningful like
control
highlight and low light and this dash
here
i think that makes it a little better
run that line and so now when we look at
those data we can see that they've been
renamed and now let's create the plot
from last time
and here we just have the the code from
the last
lesson so we don't have to write it all
again run that
and here we have the plots
so the problem with the plot in the
viewer window here is that the visual
proportions of the plot are not locked
in place
so what i mean is see i can keep moving
this around and changing
the way that this plot looks so it can
be difficult to
get plots that have consistent sizing
and proportions
and difficult to know what size to
actually make them since
you don't have a particular reference
point this is especially a problem when
you have to make multiple figures and
you want them to all look the same
there is a simple solution to keep the
size consistent while you explore the
look and feel of your plots
and to do that just use for max the
quartz function or for pcs
use the windows function and
for linux use the x11
function so of course i'm not going to
use either of these because i don't have
a linux
and i am not doing this on a windows
computer so
for this lesson i'm just going to show
you using quartz but everything is
pretty much exactly the same
just changing out what function this is
so if we just run
this we get this blank
window then after running the function
so if we run that first
now let's copy and paste that here if we
run the function and then we run this
the plot was sent to this
open graphic device window but instead
of leaving the default size
you can modify the size of the quartz
window using the height and width
arguments
or just h and w so here for example we
can say
height or h equals four and
with equals four and if we run that
and then run the plot function again it
will have created this blank window and
now created and sent this
plot directly to this open window that's
already been
sized accordingly so the default is
height equals seven and width equals
seven
and this is measured in inches however
it doesn't matter what units of measure
you typically
use just remember that you can modify
the h and the w of a plotting window
using values that range from around 1 to
10.
however if you make the window too small
you'll get an error about the figure
margins being too large
so if i make that height equals one
with equals one and run that
you can see it created this really tiny
little quartz window
and then i run plot and i get this error
in plot.new figure margin's too large
and that's just because the block can't
possibly fit inside such a tiny little
window
so you can keep playing with the sizes
of the wind note until you find
something that provides a nice
proportion between the text size and the
plot features
this is called prototyping the plot or
figure so we keep playing around with
this let's say
we settle on let's try height equals
three width equals three
let's say you know this is probably a
little too small
let's say we settle on something in
between these two so let's do 3.5
all right that looks reasonable although
see this middle label disappeared
because the plot's so small so let's
actually keep it to
four for now i'll teach you some tricks
on how to resolve that in the future
but for now whoops that's still a bit
too small let's make it 4.5
okay that looks good and reasonably
sized and proportional
then to save this plot make sure that
the quartz window is selected
so make sure you click on it and then go
to the menu
up here rstudio or
on a windows or linux you might have
something else but
i'm pretty sure on a windows you might
have to go to up to file
but either way one of these buttons up
here should give you the option to save
it
click save and then we will save this
inside our intro to data visualization
folder
let's actually go to notes
all right and we'll save it in results
okay and we'll call this
my first plot so i always recommend that
you save your figures
as pdfs and the reason
it's really nice is because pdfs
maintain and
hold on to all the information so
there's no loss of resolution
that also means it's a larger file size
so eventually
when you submit for a publication you'll
probably want to convert it to a jpeg
but for now or tiff
tiff but for now pdf works well
and if you ever do want to convert them
to a different file type
leave this as a pdf save it and then
open it in your system viewer so for
example
in your preview app on a mac open it in
that
and export it as a jpeg all right so
let's save that
close it all right and now if we go to
files here
go back to our root directory
go to results we can see that we have
our first plot here
you can also save plots by manually
going to the export button in the figure
viewer pane
so here if we go to our plot we can go
to export right here
and we can save it as a pdf or save it
as a jpeg or
other image file type here and then here
we can also set the size
just like we were setting the size
before using the quartz or windows
function
but again the advantage of this is that
you can quickly prototype here
we're saving it without really knowing
what this size is going to do
all right so that's it for this lesson i
hope this was helpful for learning how
to save and export your plots
in summary we went over prototyping
plots using a graphic window
using the quartz function on a mac or
windows function on a pc
or x11 on a linux computer
and then saving plots using the window
and using the
export button in the plot viewer all
right so i hope you enjoyed that
and next we have an exercise file where
i'm going to go over a series of
questions
to test your skills thus far and then
following that will be a video with all
the solutions to those questions